what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some Venom 3 reported
plot leaks for the film and also a
little bit for Madame Webb because
apparently these two movies Venom 3 and
Madame web are going to connect to each
other and not only is madam Webb going
to connect to Venom 3 but the other
Venom films as well now Tom Hardy has
basically confirmed already that this is
indeed the final Venom movie and a lot
of people are really really hoping that
Spider-Man is going to appear in the
movie specifically they are hoping that
we can get a Venom vs Spider-Man fight
Tom Hardy has already said a couple of
times in different interviews that if he
is in the Olympics then Spider-Man vs
Venom is that gold medal and he would be
stupid not to go for that gold medal
heavily implying that the goal for Venom
3 is to have Spider-Man in the film then
we got the post-credits scene for Venom
Let There Be Carnage and the
post-credits scene for Spider-Man no way
home and although it was a bit of a
tease bringing Venom into the m MCU and
then taking him back out it did show him
who Spider-Man was and if this plot leak
ends up being true there is a very
important part of the Venom Let There Be
Carnage post-credits scene that will
come into play in venom 3 that connects
Venom to Spider-Man so let's just go
ahead and dive into this plot leak it is
posted anonymously on 4chan so of course
take it with a grain of salt but if this
does end up being true I do like the
connections that we are seeing here for
the Sony Spider-Man universe so it
starts off by stating that this movie
Venom 3 is going to be a standalone
sequel to Madame web which is about the
titular character and three Spider Woman
protecting a pregnant Mary Parker and an
unborn Peter Parker from time traveler
Ezekiel Sims now we already know that
Ezekiel Sims is indeed going to be the
villain of this movie we've already seen
him in set photos and yes while he is
not a villain per se in the comics it
looks like Sony is switching that up on
us and perhaps he's going to be a
combination of Ezekiel and Moreland
Moreland in the comics is a multiversal
spider-verse traveler and he goes down
and he hunts people who have the powers
of Spider-Man and different universes
he's the villain in the comics and sword
of the spider totem story so perhaps
they are forging these two characters
here and perhaps making them one now as
far as the three Spider Woman are
concerned we have recently heard that
there is indeed going to be a Spider
Woman in the film in fact we just
learned that actress Sydney Sweeney is
going to be playing Spider-Woman a
Spider Woman in the film so so far this
checks out also there have been reports
that there is indeed going to be a baby
Peter Parker in the film we do also know
that actress Emma Roberts is going to be
playing Mary Parker so so far everything
is lining up but the leak continues by
stating Madam Webb will be set 10 years
before Venom one which is why the
earlier set leaks for that film have an
early 2000s setting so this is how Madam
Webb is going to link to Venom one and
them too and then of course Venom 3.
Madame web is a multiversal character
she is a cosmic entity in the comics who
can travel the entire Multiverse and it
looks like this film Madame Webb is
going to be jumping to different points
in time during it but after it ends it's
going to connect to Venom 3. but here's
where the post credit for Venom Let
There Be Carnage comes in the leak
continues to state that Venom learns
through the aforementioned multiversal
hive mind that Peter Parker Spider-Man
is destined to kill them and they
reference Sam raimi's Spider-Man 3 with
Topher Grace's Venom okay so take it
back to the post-credits scene for Venom
Let There Be Carnage where Eddie asks
Venom if he has secrets from him they're
watching a show and Venom says we all
have a past Eddie and Eddie asks if he's
keeping secrets from him and Venom says
this and it's very important he says 80
billion light years of Hive knowledge
across universes would explode your tiny
little brain Eddie says what does that
even mean and Venom is about to give him
a little taste of the hive knowledge he
says just a fraction but then Venom and
Eddie got brought into the MCU where
they saw the TV screen talking about Tom
Holland Spider-Man and it did kind of
look like Venom knew who that was and
that is probably because of the hive
knowledge then in the post-credits scene
for Spider-Man no way home Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock says maybe I should go visit
the Spider-Man but of course he gets
brought back to the Sony verse but I'm
assuming he's still going to want to go
find the Spider-Man person and they do
address this in the league we're about
to get to it but they continue to say
this is what earlier leaks were
referring to when they said that Venom
slash Eddie would explore the Multiverse
they are simply looking through it via
the Symbiote vision and this makes sense
so venom through the hive mind can look
at other universes and can look at the
past so it's clear that they're going to
be looking at Spider-Man 3 where Topher
Grace was Venom and he was fighting
Spider-Man and here's where things get
kind of interesting so they say Venom
learns that through the hive mind that
Spider-Man is destined to kill them it
then says that venom persuades Eddie to
kidnap the 10 year old heater Parker of
their Universe in order to change their
future but Eddie refuses to harm him so
this part is very interesting and also
could be kind of a letdown Spider-Man
that's only 10 years old in the universe
obviously we're not going to have a
Spider-Man vs Venom kind of storyline if
this is indeed the case Peter Parker
isn't even Spider-Man at 10 years old
but let's finish going over the league
before we talk about all of that it says
that Eddie Venom wind up forming a bond
with the 10 year old Peter Parker and
must protect him while detective Patrick
Mulligan becomes toxin he goes insane
attributed to the imperfect symbiosis
and sets out to destroy all monsters
including Venom and for some reason
Peter Parker now what's interesting
about this is this sets it up for a
really cool kind of classic origin story
for Peter Parker the Symbiote bonding
with him and then Peter Parker rejecting
it so this states that Eddie and Venom
bond with Peter Parker now of course
that could be just like bonding as
friends but it also could mean the
Symbiote bonding with Peter Parker and
they could be a perfect match and Venom
could really really like that but again
keep in mind Peter Parker is only 10
years old according to this leak so he
doesn't have his Spider-Man Powers yet
however according to the final thing
that this leak says it states that at
one point Venom exposes young Peter to
normal spiders one of which bites him
and causes an allergic reaction which
leads to Eddie having to take Peter to
the hospital and pretend to be his
father that's pretty interesting to hear
however it doesn't say that he gets bit
by a radioactive spider or a mutated
spider anything like that it just says
normal spiders so perhaps this isn't
where he gets his powers because 10
years old is still young for a Peter
Parker to receive these Spider-Man
Powers okay so a couple of things about
this plot leak if it is indeed true I'm
not sure I like it too much although the
story is very intriguing if this is is
indeed the last Venom film with Tom
Hardy's Venom I would much prefer him to
fight Spider-Man I would rather them
bring in Andrew Garfield Spider-Man and
then Venom and Spider-Man go head to
head that's what I would prefer however
having said that this does seem like a
storyline that Sony would do especially
since it does seem very clear now that
Sony does have a plan for their spider
verse they have an overall story that is
going to connect and Madame Webb is
really the first movie that is supposed
to kick off the multiversal spider-verse
with different universes and different
timelines connecting to each other so
this does kind of line up with what Sony
seems to be doing right now and in all
honesty this does seem like something
Sony would do after all with the Venom
movies they did completely change his
origin so it seems like they're trying
to be unique with their stories in their
spider-verse which does make sense and
in all honesty this story isn't that bad
it's a good twist the problem is we all
want to see a Spider-Man vs Venom movie
and perhaps Sony and Marvel Studios have
made a deal that that is coming in a
future Tom Holland Spider-Man movie in
the MCU that could be why we're not
going to get it in venom 3. but in all
honesty it would be cool to see Tom
Holland Spider-Man go up against Venom
in the MCU but again take this Leak with
a grain of salt it was posted
anonymously on 4chan so it is in no way
confirmed however let me know what you
think about this if this does come true
will you be happy will you be sad mad
let me know all of your thoughts in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
Spider-Man Venom Sony spider-verse news
everything and of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf